JOHN MERRIFIELD: Hey, everybody.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
Is everybody excited
to see Lindsey?
[APPLAUSE]
Well, just as a little
introduction in case people
don't know who Lindsey is,
she has over a billion views
on YouTube.
She was just-- we're
here for the book, right?
It is now a "New York
Times" top 10 bestseller.
Yeah?
[APPLAUSE]
And with no further ado, we want
to welcome Lindsey Stirling up
on the stage.
Welcome, Lindsey.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Hey.
Hi.
[APPLAUSE]
Hey.
Thank you, guys, for the warm
welcome, and the nice remarks.
I appreciate that.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Well, it's
kind of like welcome home.
I mean, welcome back to Google.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Thank you.
Yeah, you know, I owe all my
success to this platform that
has been great been
created by Google,
so this is like home
for me, I guess.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: So tell us
over here about your new book,
"The Only Pirate at the Party,"
which is a lovely title.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Thank you.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Can you
first take us back to violin,
and talk to us about
how you started violin,
and when you knew music is
something you wanted to do.
LINDSEY STIRLING: So
I started the violin
when I was six years old, and
it was because my parents,
they used to play classical
music on this old record
player in our
house all the time,
and they would take us to
orchestra concerts in LA
at the time was where we lived.
And I noticed that
the violinists,
they got all the
solos, they got to play
the fast, interesting parts.
And so I started
begging my parents
for lessons when I was tiny.
And I started when I was six.
And it was always
something I loved,
and something that I always
saw as a glorified hobby.
I went to college, actually, for
something completely different,
just because I always
wanted to keep it my hobby.
I was always wanted
to love music.
I never wanted to resent it.
And then when I was sitting
in class at college,
all I could think
about was music.
I was studying to
be a therapist,
and I was spending all my
free time at open mic nights
and with bands,
and I just realized
I'm always going to regret this
if I don't chase after this.
I have to give it a try.
And thank heavens I did.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Worked
out all right, I think.
So you talked about your
parents briefly there.
Can you tell us a
little more about--
and you say this in your
book-- about your parents
and the influence
they had on you
younger, and that motivation?
LINDSEY STIRLING: Yeah.
My parents were
always so supportive
of me and my sisters, all
of us expressing ourselves,
and expressing our creativity.
And whether it was my mom
teaching me how to sew,
or them encouraging me to
pursue music, or my dad,
he was a writer, and he would
read as bedtime stories scripts
that he had written when
he was trying to make it
in the movie business.
And so I just grew up with this
idea that creativity is life,
and creativity is therapeutic.
It's everything.
It's fun it's joyous.
And also, I think the fact
that my dad chased his dream
when he was young.
And he had all these stories
about going places, and meeting
people, and shaking their hands.
And I remember I'd tell my
dad, even when I was tiny,
Dad, I want to live
a life like you.
I want to go places.
I want to shake people's hands.
And I think I attribute a
lot of where I'm at today
because my dad
chased his dreams.
And even though it almost
gave me more courage
to chase them because he
felt like he was better,
even though he didn't
get his, necessarily,
at the time he was
chasing them, he still
had all these amazing stories
and was better for it.
And so I was like,
well, even for trying,
it's OK to try and not get
exactly to where you want,
because you'll get somewhere.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Yeah.
So your family has
a writing gene.
LINDSEY STIRLING: It does.
I'm in a family of
literary writers.
My parents were
both English majors.
My sister Brooke
wrote my book with me,
or was the writer of the book.
And so--
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN MERRIFIELD: And
Brooke, give us a wave.
You're going to come up here a
little later and talk further.
[APPLAUSE]
LINDSEY STIRLING: I
can't steal the credit,
because she's in the room.
Just kidding.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: So what
are your thoughts on-- a lot
of YouTubers are writing books.
Was that a motivation
for you as well?
Or what are your
thoughts on that?
LINDSEY STIRLING: Actually,
we started the book
three years ago, and
I'm sure they all
started theirs years before.
We all probably were working on
them silently at the same time.
And I think it's really awesome
that my YouTube friends,
they're my peers, we
all started together
in this weird world
of YouTube, where
we were the rejects of the
entertainment industry.
We were seen as, oh,
they're YouTubers.
We were the freak category.
And so it's so cool to
see these people that
are my friends-- we're like a
little sorority that's grown up
together-- and to see
Grace get a show on TV,
and then to see Miranda
on "Jimmy Fallon"
and a writing a
book, and everybody
doing these amazing
things, and winning awards.
It's like go team, internet.
We're a family, and so
it's really exciting.
And we all have
each other's books,
and we send them to each.
It's a family.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Awesome.
And so within your book,
what was your main motivation
to start out and think, I've
had this amazing career.
Let's write a book, talk
a little further about it.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Yeah, well, I
wanted it to be several things.
I wanted people to read it,
and laugh, and enjoy it,
and be filled with positivity.
But at the same time, I think
one of the big motivations
to write the book was I felt
like I had some experiences
and stories that I wanted to
share, because here at meet
and greets and at shows,
people will ask me questions.
And it's a very quick
process at a meet and greet.
You don't get to spend an
hour chatting with someone.
And girls would whisper to
me, I struggle with anorexia.
How did you get through it?
And what do you say to
someone in that moment?
And so it just made me
think over and over again,
gosh, when I was going through
depression and anorexia,
I felt so isolated and so alone.
And people are
very afraid to talk
about those kind of things.
And it took me a
really long time
to even realize I had a
problem, because I thought,
no, depression I
don't have that.
That's not me.
But the thing is, I think
that this is something
that a lot of people,
unknowingly or knowingly,
go through.
And so I wanted to
bring awareness to it,
and also provide,
hopefully, hope for someone.
Like when I felt
hopeless, hopefully they
can find hope, and realize
that they can get through it,
and they can be who
they want to be.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Now, you have
a chapter called "Life with Ed."
Do you mind talking
a little bit more
about the title of that
and that experience?
LINDSEY STIRLING: Totally.
So "Life without
Ed" is a book that I
read when I was
struggling with anorexia,
and it was probably one of the
most helpful books that I read.
I read a lot about anorexia
when I realized I had a problem.
And it was a book where it
separated the eating disorder
and this girl.
Her therapist had taught her
to call her eating disorder Ed.
And so for the first time
I realized, oh my gosh,
my eating disorder isn't me.
It's not my brain.
This is something
that has come into me,
and it's something
that I can get out.
It's a separate part of my
brain that I can say, go away.
And in and this book, she
talks to her eating disorder,
and she calls it, and
she personifies it.
And so these voices that
would come into her head
telling her negative
things, and telling her
that she was
worthless, or whatever,
she would talk
back to this voice
with the other
side of her brain,
and say, no, I'm not worthless.
And she would have
these conversations.
And as much as it sounds
schizophrenic and multiple
personality
disorder, I did this.
And it allowed me to feel
like I had the ability
to take control
over my brain again
and kick out this very
unhealthy part of myself.
And you know, it's still there.
It's still a little part of
me that will always be there,
but I know how to
talk to it now.
And it actually hides
most of the time.
It's usually not there.
And when I first learned
about an eating disorder,
and I first started
researching it,
I was so upset, because I read
that it's an incurable disease.
And I was like,
who wants to hear
that the worst part of
yourself is incurable
and you're always
going to have it?
And now I understand why they
say that, but at the same time,
it's not a part of
my everyday life.
It's not a part
of my weekly life.
When I get really stressed
out, Ed starts to come back,
and I know how to talk to
it and tell it to go away.
And so that's why I
wanted that chapter
to be in there, because I wanted
to express that it is curable.
You can get rid of it.
You can take things
out of your life,
and you can determine
who you want to be,
and you don't have to let
the hard things we go through
determine who we are.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Yeah.
That's awesome.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So in that same experience,
opening up about that,
you're a great role
model for other people.
Do you mind talking a little
bit about your core principles
and that influence on your life?
LINDSEY STIRLING: Yeah, you
know, a lot of people ask me,
oh, how do you try
to stay grounded?
My life has literally
flipped upside down
in the last four years.
I'm in a completely
different place
than I ever thought
I would ever be in,
and everything from my personal
life to my professional life
has just changed.
And the one thing, I think,
that's kept me very consistent
is two things.
It's my family and my spiritual
beliefs, my religious beliefs.
I was raised in a very,
very religious family.
We went to church every week,
and we had specific principles
and guidelines.
And I decided when I started
to see my career taking off,
it scared me.
And I thought, what if I change?
I like the person that I am.
I like Lindsey, the
core of the person
that my parents raised me to be.
And I don't want to
become something I'm not.
I don't want to become a
scary-- you hear about how
people change, and you
know, Justin Bieber
fell off the deep end.
You're like, ahh, what do I do?
And so I made a decision.
And it was almost like
a promise to me and God.
And some people
call it-- I think
most people that are artistic
have a belief in something
greater than themselves.
And to me, it's God.
And I made a promise
to God that I
would stay true
to the principles
that I had right then,
my standards of dress,
my standards of lifestyle,
and my spirituality.
And as long as I've kept
that in the forefront
of my life and a foundation,
as much as everything else has
changed, my religious
beliefs and my family
have kept me feeling like
I'm the same Lindsey that I
have grown up to be,
and that I want to stay.
And I plan to keep that as
a foundation of my life.
And I think it's kept me sane.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Yeah.
There's a funny
chapter in your book.
This is the only spoiler I give.
But it's where you say
the chapter on drugs,
and rock 'n' roll,
and everything,
and then it's one
sentence, and it's
like, I didn't do any
of that, so moving on.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Right.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: And
that was a good chapter.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Thank you.
Thank you.
It was the easiest in the
audio book, when I got to that.
It was like, chapter down.
Yes.
JOHN MERRIFIELD:
Now, do you mind
talking a little bit about
the chapter "No Man's Land"?
I think it starts leading up
to the title and everything.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Yeah.
You know, there
was another theme
that I wanted to
bring up in the book,
that it's OK to be different.
And one of the first
chapters in the book
says that sometimes
being different
feels a lot like being alone.
And it's not like I've gone
through my life being like,
I want to look different,
and I want to be different,
and I want to be quirky and
weird and have stand out.
A lot of times, I just feel
like every single person
is different when we're true
to our authentic selves,
and that's OK.
It's Acceptance is very
different from fitting in.
Fitting in is changing
yourself to fit with what
someone else wants you to be.
And acceptance is being
accepted by those you
love for who you really are.
And so "No Man's
Land" was a chapter
I talked about how
sometimes I feel
like I'm in the middle of
two very different worlds.
There's my religious
side and the side where
I like to be frugal,
and I drive the same car
I drove in high school.
And there's that side of myself.
And then there's this--
JOHN MERRIFIELD: You
really drive the same car
since high school.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Well,
actually in the book I do.
My car died a couple months ago.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: I know.
I thought it had died.
LINDSEY STIRLING: And I
was very sad about it.
It died on the 405,
and I just sat there
on the side of the road.
It was the third time
it died in a month,
and I was like, we're done.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: We're done.
LINDSEY STIRLING: We're done.
But when the book was completed,
I had the same-- so it's a lie.
So there's that side
of myself, and then
there's the side of myself
that I'm in the music industry,
and a lot of that
industry sometimes
falls in the sex, drugs,
and rock 'n' roll.
Not everybody, but
that's the stigma
of a lot of what you
come into contact with,
and I feel sometimes
like I toe the line
of two very different worlds.
And I'm in the middle, and
either side a lot of times
can't understand the other.
But at the end of
the chapter, it also
talks about how it's OK.
My tour manager writes me
this letter that I realize,
yes, sometimes maybe I do feel
like I'm in no man's land,
but there are people
that understand me,
and there are people that
I've surrounded myself
with that get it, and love
that about me, and respect it.
And so I've just learned,
over and over again,
even in these times when I'm
like, oh I feel like I'm alone,
there are always people that
that's why they love you,
is for the things that
make you different.
And no one's really
in no man's land.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Wow.
So YouTube being your main
platform, you write about this,
but it's a very public
platform, right?
That you can comment,
people can comment.
You can see that.
Tell us about how
when you first started
getting really big
on YouTube, how
you dealt with maybe the
comments, the good, the bad,
And how you went through that.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Yes.
You know, it's interesting.
I have some friends that are
YouTubers that say, oh, you
get used to the comments.
You just ignore them, and it
doesn't matter at some point.
Maybe I'm different, but I
feel like the hurtful comments,
they're always going
to hurt a little bit,
especially when they
you in that spot
that you're sensitive
to, that you're like,
oh, I was hoping nobody
would comment on that.
Everybody has their
little things.
I don't know if any of
you watch "The Bachelor,"
but the gal was
talking about her toes.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Yeah,
she started crying, right?
LINDSEY STIRLING: She's
starts crying about her toes.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Not that
I watch it, but my wife--
[LAUGHTER]
LINDSEY STIRLING: Caught ya!
Your wife, right?
Your wife.
Anyways, I thought
that was hilarious,
but that's a sidenote.
But yeah, everybody has their
things that are just like,
oh my gosh, not that.
But you learn that
there is so much more
good than there is ever bad.
There's a ton of really
positive comments,
and then there's one
that may be really nasty.
But why is it that we
let the bad stick out
so much more than the good?
And so it's just
trying to refocus.
Because there's always
different places of your mind
where you can go, but
there's one stage.
And things come in and out,
thoughts come in and out
all the time, and it's
what thoughts are you
going to entertain?
What thoughts are
you going to let
stay on the stage of your
mind, and which ones are you
going to kick off really fast?
And so I've learned
to just you take it
all with a grain of
salt. You move on,
and try to focus on the good.
And especially as you get
bigger and bigger as a YouTuber,
you get more and more your fans.
And I have my
little Stirlingites,
and they will defend
me to the death.
And if there's a
negative comment,
I usually don't see it, because
they defend me so hardcore.
How dare you say that
Lindsey's hair looks messy.
Whatever it is.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: So I would like
to invite you sister Brooke up.
If you don't mind, we
can invite Brooke up.
[APPLAUSE]
LINDSEY STIRLING:
Brooke, Brooke, Brooke.
BROOKE PASSEY: Thank you.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Well,
welcome, Brooke, to the stage.
BROOKE PASSEY: Thank you.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: So I would
love to talk to both of you
a little bit about
writing this book.
Now, I know it took
a few years, but how
was it, tour life
and the balance,
and writing this book together.
Just would you mind talking
a little bit more about that?
BROOKE PASSEY: Yeah, it
was difficult at first
because, she's traveling
around the world,
and we don't live in the
same state in general.
So we did a lot
of it over Skype.
Almost-- I just feel like
90% was written via Skype.
So we would just
try and find times,
and she's like in a
completely different timezone.
So I'd get up really
early, and she'd
stay up late after
a show, and we'd
Skype at really weird times.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Or
Google+, occasionally.
Google hangout.
BROOKE PASSEY:
Actually, yes, we would.
We would use Gmail.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: I'm joiking.
LINDSEY STIRLING: We actually
did, because it depended.
In different countries,
one would be stronger
than the other.
BROOKE PASSEY: Yeah, we're
like, Skype is not working.
Let's go to Gchat.
LINDSEY STIRLING: So there
you go, our little plug.
The superior platform,
if you know what I mean.
But it was funny.
I remember several nights.
We're both really
tired, and we're like,
I can't understand you.
It's all broken up.
I think I understand
what you're saying.
BROOKE PASSEY: Yeah, I got it.
Just move on.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: So tell us a
little bit more about-- again,
you talk a lot about your
relationship and everything.
Tell us a little more
about that and how
it developed, and especially
as you started touring more,
doing more, how you
kept that intact.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Yeah.
Well, Brooke and I have been--
we shared a room as kids.
We were best buddies.
We were roommates in college.
She's come on tour with me.
So Brooke, it was great to
have her write the book,
because she's been there through
almost every stage of my life
and seen it firsthand,
known the people.
But it talks about
in the book how
there was a time--
our relationship is
throughout the book, and you
see that there's a time when
we lost that a little bit.
And it was when I was going
through my eating disorder,
and I lost sight of everything.
And our relationship was
probably the biggest loss
that I had from my
eating disorder,
when we became like
strangers, basically.
BROOKE PASSEY: We were living
together in the same room,
and somehow we just
totally drifted.
And we didn't even know
each other anymore.
So writing the book was
actually really cool.
But by the time she
asked me write it,
we had mended that a little bit.
But the process of writing
it was really, really
cool, because it was almost like
a healing for the both of us
at the same time, because we
got to work together and just
relive all that
and go through it.
It's been really, really cool.
LINDSEY STIRLING:
The good and the bad,
we both cried when
we read that chapter.
BROOKE PASSEY: Yeah,
we're laughing and crying.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Oh my
god, this is so good.
I feel it.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: And
this is your first book?
BROOKE PASSEY: It is.
It's my first book.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Wow.
Yeah, not bad. "New
York Times" bestseller.
LINDSEY STIRLING: I know.
She's a bestselling author.
JOHN MERRIFIELD:
Yeah, that's great.
[APPLAUSE]
So we would love to take some
questions from the crowd,
if you have any.
And we'll have some microphones
that we pass around.
I want to talk to you a
little bit about college.
And you're graduating
soon, right?
LINDSEY STIRLING: I
graduated just last fall.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Last fall?
That's great.
LINDSEY STIRLING: I did.
I'm a graduate.
[APPLAUSE]
That's right.
I was working on my internship.
I left school right
when I-- All I had left.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: You
had to do an internship?
LINDSEY STIRLING: All I
had left was an internship,
and they would not let
me graduate without it.
So I was doing little
internship projects
while I was on my last
tour for the last year.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: What did
you do for your internship?
LINDSEY STIRLING: So I'm
now a recreation management
therapist, everyone.
So for my internship
I had wanted
to work with at-risk youth.
And so I would have treatment
centers bring out their youth,
or I'd go speak to them on tour
days, or I'd have them come out
and come to sound check, and
I would do a little speech,
and talk to them, and
answer theirs questions.
So that's how I
did my internship.
And it was really fun.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: That's awesome.
LINDSEY STIRLING:
And it was funny.
I was at graduation and
wearing the cap and gown
and everything, super excited.
And I was at BYU.
And all these people were
whispering in front of me,
and then someone tugged
on my little cap,
and they were like,
why are you here?
I'm graduating.
I'm not wearing this for style.
JOHN MERRIFIELD:
You're just going
to bust out and
start playing violin.
BROOKE PASSEY: They
thought you were doing
a music video or something.
LINDSEY STIRLING:
Yeah, they're like,
is it an impromptu music video?
Yes.
Yes, I wanted the cap and gown.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: So why was
that important for you, though?
I mean, obviously you are well
established in your career
and doing well, but
why still graduate?
LINDSEY STIRLING: You
know, I worked so hard.
I put myself through college.
I worked really hard to work
a day job, go to school,
and pursue music.
And it was something
my entire life,
I always knew I would graduate.
I always knew I
would have a degree.
And also, it was
something I believed in.
I really did want to become
a recreational therapist.
And so I couldn't live with
the fact that I was so close
and I had something that
was so important to me
that I never finished.
And so I was like, I
will get that degree.
And everyone told
me also-- I always
get inspired and
motivated when people
say I won't do something.
And everyone's like, oh
you'll never come back.
And I was like, yes, I will.
Yes, I will.
I'll get that degree.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Yeah, we
saw that with "America's Got
Talent," right?
LINDSEY STIRLING: That's right.
I will come back,
and you'll invite me.
BROOKE PASSEY: You'll like it.
LINDSEY STIRLING:
And you will love it.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: That's awesome.
So we have a question
from the crowd.
AUDIENCE: So I wanted
to ask a little bit
about the transition from
classical to not classical
and how that happened.
So I was classically
trained as a piano player
and then became a
computer programmer,
which is a little bit different
as well, but actually not
too uncommon.
I think a lot of
us here do that.
But I want to hear about
classic violin to your style.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Yes, so
I'm very grateful that I
was classically trained.
Because those chops as
a classical musician,
that's important stuff.
That's the foundation
of my playing.
But I just got really burnt out.
And I remember, it was right
before I went to college,
and I was trying to decide
whether I wanted to study music
or not.
Like I said, I was
trying to keep it fun,
but I was like, I don't
enjoy this anymore.
I don't love it, and
I used to love it.
And it made me really sad.
And so it just
clicked in my head.
Well, I need to play the kind
of music I like to listen to.
And so I started jamming
with stuff on the radio,
and I started to play with
bands and write my own music.
And I just really started
to take music into my hands,
rather than just
molding into what
the violin was supposed to be.
And my passion just
got reinvigorated.
It became more and more fun,
and I started moving to music.
It looked really
awkward at first.
And then it just evolved from
there, where I found my sound.
And that's when I started.
I was like, I'm going
to make an album
with this weird, random sound.
And it turned out, I
guess, really great.
It worked.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: And
you said had literally
practiced dancing and playing in
front of your roommates, right?
BROOKE PASSEY: Yes.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Yes.
I can't believe--
BROOKE PASSEY: She actually
used their bedroom to practice,
because ours was too messy.
LINDSEY STIRLING:
Oh, I didn't know
you were going to say that.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: I don't
know if that's in the books,
so it's a good tidbit.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Good
times, good times.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thank you so much
for coming today.
So I have a question.
So you mentioned that
your faith really helped
when you were sick at the time.
So would you please elaborate
more, and in what specific way?
LINDSEY STIRLING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LINDSEY STIRLING: I had been
brought up my whole life
to believe that I was a daughter
of God, and that he created me,
and he loved me.
And anything that you create
we think is beautiful.
If you have a child, you
think it's beautiful.
I'm a new mother of a dog.
I think she's beautiful.
But anyways, anything that
you are a parent of, you love.
And so I really had to
delve back into that.
At this time when I felt
unlovable, and I felt ugly,
and I just thought
I was worthless,
I had to remember that
I'm a child of God,
and I had to rely on
that, that he loves me,
he thinks I'm beautiful,
and I need to love myself,
so that I can go out.
Because you can't
love anyone else.
You can't give any
energy to someone else
unless you first are
OK with who you are.
And so I had to heal
myself so that I
could go out and be
the kind of person
that God wanted me to be.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Ian.
I just wanted to
say I'm a huge fan,
and I'm actually
a figure skater.
And I don't know if
you know, but there's
a huge following for you in
the figuring skating community,
where a lot of
skaters are using some
of your music for their
numbers, primarily
"Crystallize" and "Element."
I'm working on trying to do
something with "Anti Gravity."
LINDSEY STIRLING: Oh, really?
That's cool.
AUDIENCE: But one of
things I wanted to ask you,
you mentioned something earlier
about the music industry.
And I'm curious, when you
started creating your album,
was there any pressure
in terms of the direction
that some of the songs
had to be created with?
Was there a compromise
that had to be done,
or just everything was
organic, and it was like,
this is what I want, and
nobody tell you what to do?
LINDSEY STIRLING: Yeah.
Well, it was at the time
my biggest disappointment.
I could not get a record
label, and I didn't understand
much about the music industry.
But in my mind,
how it worked was,
you had to get a
record label if anyone
was going to hear your tunes.
And then luckily, right
while this was going on,
I discovered the
wonderful land of YouTube,
and realized, oh my gosh.
Because I kept hearing,
you're just too different.
People wanted to put me in a
box of what was successful,
and they're like,
you're way out there.
And this is what
we know will work,
and you're way over there.
And so people were trying
to get me to compromise
my music in the weirdest
ways, ways that I was like,
that would never work for me.
That's not who I am.
And so I just kept waiting.
I just kept writing,
waiting, hopefully,
for someone to love
what I was writing.
And then, like I said,
I discovered YouTube.
And I was so excited
because I realized
very quickly that here
is a land where I can
make my music in my own way.
I could do it on my own timing.
I can do it the way
I want, and there's
people that want to hear it.
I don't have to wait
for someone to tell me
I'm good enough, because all
these people are clicking
on the links, and
they're liking it,
and I can see the
iTunes sales spiking
every time I release a video.
And so, no, it was all just
the music I wanted to create,
and my fans told
me they liked it.
And that's the cool thing
you realize on the internet.
There's a niche for everything.
And so what you create,
create it and they will come.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: What are they?
The Stirlingites,
is that what it is?
LINDSEY STIRLING:
Yes, the Stirlingites.
JOHN MERRIFIELD:
Stirlingites, all right.
LINDSEY STIRLING:
I didn't make them.
They made themselves that.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Another
question back here.
AUDIENCE: So there's also
the unfortunate niche
of people who want to
say terrible things
on the internet.
And you mentioned
this a little bit,
but I'm curious, being on the
receiving end, not a lot of us
are on the receiving end as
much as you are, probably,
of all kinds of comments.
First of all, why do
you think they do that?
But secondly and
more importantly,
what can we do as just
humans to help the problem?
What can we do as Google
to help the problem?
In your opinion, what
can be done about this?
Because it's pretty
terrible, and sometimes
it makes me ashamed
to be a human.
LINDSEY STIRLING: I
know what you mean.
With this new age of an
extreme amount of technology,
I just think human
interactions have
become less important
and less precious.
And people feel like
just because they
don't have a face
to that comment,
just because they have a
picture of a Pokemon character
as their icon and their
name is like Skittle27,
it's OK to say
really mean things,
because there's no
accountability for it.
And so that's why
I think people are.
And also, I've just realized
people want to be heard.
Everyone wants to feel
like they have a voice.
People are craving
connection, and I
think the more this
digital age takes off,
people crave it more
and more, wanting
to have an identity,
wanting to be noticed,
wanting to be heard.
And so I think that's
why a lot of people
will say really nasty things.
And then when people like my
little Stirlingites to defend,
that's what they want.
They want to fight and
get that interaction.
But I've just thought a
lot about this lately.
Even in stores, like when I'm
checking out at Walgreens,
how often am I on
my phone and not
even like looking at the
person that's helping me?
And they ask, do you
want to donate $1?
I'm like, sure.
You don't even look up at
people anymore half the time.
And so I've tried to
make a conscious effort
in my interactions,
whether it's online,
to be personal with
people, or whether it's
in person, to actually look
people in the eye and say,
how was your day?
I think we're all
craving connection,
and people reach out in
weird ways sometimes for it.
AUDIENCE: If you could
do a collaboration
with any other artist, past
or present, alive or dead,
who would you pick and why?
LINDSEY STIRLING: Alive or dead?
That's so hard.
OK, I've got two that are dead.
One of them is a no-brainer.
Michael Jackson, oh my gosh.
I would have him give
me a dance tutorial,
and we would do a
remake of "Beat it."
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Oh wow.
LINDSEY STIRLING: And
then, also, my other one, I
would love to do a comedy
sketch with Lucille Ball.
I love Lucille Ball.
She's my hero.
What about you, Brooke?
BROOKE PASSEY: I'm nobody.
I don't like being in
front of the camera.
LINDSEY STIRLING: We're the
same, but really different.
It's really funny.
OK.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: That's awesome.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: This
question is actually
coming more from my mother,
who has actually been a violin
teacher for 40 years now.
And she has very much fallen
in love with your music,
and also her students
have as well.
And so she wants to thank
you for that, first of all,
for motivating a lot
of very young people
to basically increase
their motivation
to learn how to play the
violin, and to actually
continue to want to do that.
And it's really fun
to watch her play that
along with your students
like at old folks
homes and different places,
watch the old folks get up
and start dancing
and things like that.
But the question
that she has is she's
been taking a lot of your
arrangements and your pieces
and trying to simplify them
a little bit so that younger
people can play them.
And so the question
is, is that something
that you've considered doing?
Have you consider making--
because a lot of your pieces
are very difficult. So
that's the question,
is have you ever considered
creating even simpler versions
of the music that you have?
LINDSEY STIRLING: You know,
that's such a good-- I have.
I want to make a violin tutorial
method, like a series of books.
There's pretty
much one out there.
It's pretty much one
method that everybody uses.
And so I wanted to
replace it, but to be
a supplement to that method
and intersperse my songs along
with classical violin songs.
And yeah, simplify some of them.
I have not done it yet, but
it's definitely something
that I really wanted to do.
So it's on my list.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering
what's the good and bad
of moving from what you
were doing to getting
professional management?
LINDSEY STIRLING: Oh,
well, it's been very great.
So when I started, I was doing
literally everything myself,
from thinking of the video
ideas and the creative side
that I still do and
still love to do,
but also, anytime someone
ordered a piece of merchandise,
I was the one that
rolled up the poster,
stuck it in an envelope,
wrote a thank you note,
and stuck in there, went to
the post office and mailed it.
I did everything, and
it was overwhelming.
I couldn't I couldn't focus.
I stopped being able to
focus on the creative,
and I was starting to
just run dry of ideas
because I was so overwhelmed.
And so getting with
a management company,
it was actually a
really cool process,
because when I was
searching for management,
I was very much like,
don't try to change me.
I'm the way am.
I like to be very hands-on.
And also, YouTube is the base.
I don't want a record label.
And so I was
looking for somebody
that could take who I
was, and then just add
their knowledge of the
actual real music industry
and how it works.
And so it's this
amazing thing where
we've learned from each other.
I found the right
management company.
My manager's right
back there in the back.
Adina, give a wave.
[APPLAUSE]
I would say that the
hard thing about it
is just finding
the right manager.
It was really hard.
I was managerless
for quite a while
because I was searching
for the right fit.
It's like dating, you know?
It's like looking
for-- because I
felt like I was going on all
these dates with management
companies and meetings.
And then finally, when
you find the right people,
it clicks, and
it's been amazing.
But yeah, that process
was exhausting.
AUDIENCE: I know you've worked
with an old friend of mine,
Devin Graham.
I went to high school with him.
We shot a video together.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Nice.
AUDIENCE: And I know
you've worked with him.
I think you still do, your
latest Final Fantasy video,
I think.
And you also had a relationship
with him for a good while.
How has--
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Sorry.
Just throwing that one in there.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Am I blushing?
Yes.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: You dated him,
in case you didn't know that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I know.
It's not there anymore,
but you're still working.
You're still working
with him after the fact.
And I just wanted to know
how, having worked with him,
how easygoing, or was
it difficult to work
with other celebrities?
Like YouTubers?
You were saying you have many
friends who are YouTubers.
How does working and having
a relationship with one
affect your career?
LINDSEY STIRLING: Yeah,
I actually met Devin.
He's the one that introduced
me to the YouTube world.
He contacted me.
I saw this little video I had.
And it was my "America's
Got Talent" video he saw.
And he reached out
to me, and was like,
I think you would do
really well on YouTube.
And I was just like,
I didn't understand.
I was like, YouTube?
I don't get it.
And so he actually taught this.
He used to teach classes
on here's YouTube.
Be introduced to
the land of YouTube.
This is how you be a YouTuber.
And I went to one
of his classes.
He invited me, and
I was like, wow.
What?
And my life was
changed in that moment.
And I was like, this is
what I'm going to do.
And so I owe so much to Devin
Graham, because not only
that, we started
working together a ton,
we started dating.
But it was amazing.
The two of us were chasing
our dreams together,
and we are getting to
travel the world together,
and both doing what we loved.
And we would help each other
with our projects, which
was amazing, and really hard
to end a relationship, though,
that's based on everything.
We were each other's
best friends.
We were dating.
We were also each other's
coworkers, pretty much.
We did everything together.
And so I remember
thinking my career
was over when we ended it.
I was like, OK, that was the
worst decision I ever made.
I didn't know how I
was going to continue,
because he was my
cinematographer.
He was my partner-in-crime.
And so it was really interesting
to renavigate the waters.
How do I do this
without the guy that
taught me everything I
know, and has helped me
every step of the way so far?
But like I said,
I owe everything
pretty much that I have to
what Devin Graham did for me,
and he's an amazing person.
So here's to Devinsupertramp.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN MERRIFIELD: So what's
next for Lindsey Stirling?
LINDSEY STIRLING: What's next?
You know, this book is what's
been next for so long, so it's
crazy that now it's out.
And now I'm working
on an album, and I'm
really excited about it.
I'm about halfway
done with it, and it's
going to come out in
June, fingers crossed.
It's my self-proclaimed
deadline.
But yeah, and I'm super
stoked about that.
We'll be touring and doing
festivals through the summer
and touring in the fall.
So that's pretty much
what's next for me.
JOHN MERRIFIELD: Cool.
Well, thank you so much
for your time, Lindsey.
This was really good.
LINDSEY STIRLING: Yeah,
thank you guys for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
Hey, guys.
Thank you so much for
watching today and joining us.
I also wanted to talk a
little bit about a charity
that I support.
It's called Operation
Underground Railroad,
and it deals with
human trafficking.
And this group goes
in, and they save kids
from human trafficking
and slavery.
And it's a huge issue
today that a lot of us
don't like to talk
about, and it's amazing.
It saves lives.
So you can click the
upper-right-hand corner
to donate, and also to
find out more about it.
Thanks, guys.